What is the best way to know if you have H. Pylori?
Well, H. Pylori can play into that last question of having a lot of gas and stomach issues too,
but H. Pylori, number one, the reason why people get H. Pylori is because they have hypochloridria.
So, just so we talked about in the last question about hypochloridria is the number one,
you know, bowel health issue worldwide, H. Pylori follows a close second because it's caused from decrease hydrochloric acid production in the stomach.
That effect according to the World Health Organization, H. Pylori infections are the number one bacterial infection worldwide.
Because it's so often silent, you know, there's the majority of people have a silent H. Pylori issue.
H. Pylori is a major player for heart disease, heart diseases, the number one cause of death in the United States.
It's a very common condition, and typically they don't know that they haven't sometimes ever.
Because usually you have a cord area to have heart attack and you go into the hospital and they all their check-in is blocked.
Heart disease, they might do a bypass or put a stint in, but they're never addressing the reason why.
I don't know of anybody's ever told me, like cardiologist suspects H. Pylori infectionity, what would be on, you know, whatever, for H. Pylori.
No, they don't ever do that. So, best way to know if you have H. Pylori, there's many different tests.
If you have H. Pylori, you're able to, you read a breath test that you breathe in, you blow out the air through this tube and it measures possibility of H. Pylori in the gut.
But if you don't have H. Pylori in the stomach any longer because it goes systemic and affects your arteries, affects all sorts of different things, it will show a false negative.
There is a H. Pylori test with a gut test so we do a stool sample test on somebody quite often tests for H. Pylori, but if H. Pylori is in present at that time or that stool sample in the gut, it's going to also show a false negative.
There's a blood test for H. Pylori too, but unless H. Pylori is present in the blood which is very unlikely that it's going to be in the blood, it's going to also be a false negative.
Because it doesn't stay in the blood, you'll have sepsis, it goes into the tissues, it affects the lining of the arteries, it affects the endothelial cells, that's the inner lining, it affects the muscles underneath the endothelial cells, that's arteries, but it also goes systemic and it can affect all sorts of different organs.
Well, you're going to take a tissue sample and measure for bacterial content so the best thing to do is just to treat as if you have different symptoms.
You know, I have said that I take Burberry on a regular basis dot every day to help with H. Pylori because it is systemic and because it is major, if not the number one cause of heart disease.
And it's a major cause of other kids or so, you just can treat as if. Now I am blog post on H. Pylori.
If you look back to Pylori is what it's called, I have several blog posts about this, how to kind of walk through that and to do self treatment.